c'est un procès qui laisse beaucoup de
gens perplexes il n'est pas terminée
bien sûr mais peu importe l'issue
certains parlent déjà d'un fiasco alors
pour y voir plus clair
j'en parle avec nathalie duhamel du
regroupement québécois des centres
d'aidé et de lutte contre les agressions
à caractère sexuel et walid hijazi
qu'est avocat criminaliste bonsoir à
vous deux bonsoir métrage asie je vais
commencer avec vous parce que quand on
regarde ce qui se passe on a le
sentiment à tort ou à raison que c'est
pas le procès d'eugène gobetti mais
plutôt le procès des plaignantes
est-ce que c'est habituel dans des
procès d'agressions sexuelles que les
relations des plaignantes soit ainsi
contester cette caustique comme la
plupart des causes en matière
d'agression sexuelle d'une agression
sexuelle généralement il n'y a pas de
témoins de l'événement de ce qui s'est
passé
alors la seule preuve qui existent et
qui peut être présentable accord est la
parole de ceux et celles qui l'ont vécue
alors un rôle de l'un contre la parole
de l'autre si jamais il décide de
prendre la boîte comme on dit témoigné
l'oeil à un élément d'appréciation de
s'accréditer a lieu pour la maman c'est
le fardeau de la poursuite c'est lui qui
doivent démontrer hors de tout doute
raisonnable qui est une agression
sexuelle et leurs seules preuves sont
les témoignages des plaignantes alors dû
au niveau de la défense il est tout à
fait normal que l'avocat de la défense
il a un devoir de loyauté un devoir de
compétences et doit attaquer la
fiabilité la crédibilité de toute preuve
à charge contre les clients et casse la
preuve repose sur la parole de quelqu'un
qui n'est pas corroborée par d'autres
preuves indépendantes qui viendrait
confirmer son témoignage il faut il faut
il faut attaquer la crédibilité aller
chercher des invraisemblances des
incongruités et si on a de la preuve
contradictoires on est obligé de
confronter le témoin avec une preuve qui
vient contredire ce qu'elle a dit à la
police ou dans son témoignage précis
avoue dans un instant à la djamel mais
quand même ce qui est au coeur de ce
procès là c'est le consentement à l'as
quelque chose auquel les présumées
victimes peuvent consentir et d'autres
pas de quoi on parle exactement en
matière sexuelle le droit insiste sera
consentement clair sans ambiguïté à tous
les étapes de la relation affective et
sexuelle
alors ça peut commencer dans une
atmosphère consensuelle mais les choses
l'atmosphère charge et l'un des
protagonistes plus reculées
alors ce qu'est la corogne ultime ans et
une accusation d'agression sexuelle ce
que le fardeau de la couronne et de
démontrer premièrement qui est un
attouchement de nature sexuelle pas
nécessairement viol mais un geste de
nature sexuelle sans le consentement de
la plaignante et démontrer l'intention
coupable de dire que l'accusé savait que
la plaignante ne consentait pas à l'acte
en question madame duhamel si on sort un
instant du contexte du procès ghomeshi
vous travaillez avec des personnes
victimes d'agression sexuelle
est-ce que vous avez vu des présumées
victimes comme ça garder des relations
ou entretenir des relations avec leurs
agresseurs a légué parfois la victime ne
pense pas que le courriel ou que le
contact après l'agression et pertinents
pour sa cause alors c'est pas
nécessairement toujours un oubli mais
elle ne pense pas que c'est important de
le révéler et le procureur de la
couronne doit poser ce genre de
questions il a deux choses à faire il a
à préparer
le témoin pour que livre un témoignage
juste et clair avec les bonnes dates et
relater les faits de manière claire et
il doit aussi la préparer au contre
interrogatoire
donc il doit soulever ce qui pourrait
être utilisé comme elle mais pourquoi
une vue une présumée victime garderait
le contact avec son agresseur encore une
fois je veux pas qu'on parle
nécessairement des faits de ce procès là
mais de façon plus générale voit ça peut
ça peut être un attachement émotif ça
peut être pour recontacter pour
comprendre ce qui s'est passé et obtenir
une conclusion dans le fond pour elle de
le recontacter pour savoir exactement ce
qui s'est passé pourquoi ça s'est passé
et qu'est ce qui est arrivé en fait pis
il peut avoir aussi des enjeux d'ordre
émotionnel de l'attachement de la paix m
donc c'est pas inhabituel non je dirais
pas mais
je serai pas prête à vous dire que c'est
toujours le cas c'est toujours le cas
oui donc mettre jazy le fardeau est ce
qui n'est pas plus lourd dans ce cas-ci
dans ce genre de coop pour une
plaignante
c'est sûr que n'importe quel témoin qui
va témoigner à la cour va être assujetti
à l'épreuve du contre interrogatoire qui
par définition est une épreuve qui
difficile alors c'est sûr que lorsque
quelqu'un fait donc une dénonciation y
est ils s'offrent comme témoin à la cour
ben c'est une étape obligatoire
nécessaire que de se faire conter
interrogé et quel impact que les faits
ça pourrait avoir selon vous madame du
ms sur d'autres femmes qui auraient
envie de porter plainte
ben c'est ce que la médiatisation de ce
procès peut avoir un gros impact les
femmes craignent d'aller porter plainte
elle craint l'étape de déposer plainte à
la police
ensuite si la presse est retenue elle
doivent rencontrer le procureur de la
couronne est ensuite passé à procès et à
l'intérieur du procès c'est le défi dans
le fond du contre interrogatoire qui
crée beaucoup d'anxiété chez les femmes
et la médiation de la médiatisation de
cette cause pourrait peut-être en
refroidir davantage vous savez
en ce moment il ya quelque chose autour
de 5 à 10% de femmes qui portent plainte
à la police
alors
ça pourrait avoir un effet négatif mais
il ya pourtant eu des lois on a essayé
de mieux protéger la vie privée de
femmes victimes d'agressions sexuelles
alors est ce qu'il faudrait faire plus
c'est ce que quand vous voyez ce qui se
passe maintenant au procès l'onuci
effectivement il ya des règles qui sont
venus que ce sont le droit s'est
raffinée à s'est ajustée aux causes
d'agressions sexuelles l'historique
sexuelle d'une plaignante n'est pas
pertinent lorsque vient le temps de
témoigner sur une agression sexuelle à
une date fixe alors c'est pas parce que
quelqu'un arrive des moeurs légères que
les concernés acer agressif ceci étant
dit c'est toujours délicat diriger un
symbole en cause sociale un procès ce
qui se passe au palais de justice ce
n'est pas un débat de société sur la
violence faite aux femmes si le procès
de yann ghomeshi qu'ils étaient accusés
d'avoir commis une agression sexuelle
sur trois différentes personnes à trois
différentes dates et il faut pas sortir
de ce cadre là et tirer des généralités
d'un procès toujours un exercice délicat
et j'espère que ça ne dissuadera pas des
femmes qui ont été victimes de porter
plainte et de laisser la justice suivre
son cours il le fait que j'ai nommé
chine témoigne pas à son procès ce que
c'est inhabituel encore qu'un présumé
agresseur ne témoigne pas l'endroit
aussi la cellule obligé de témoigner et
la force actuelle de la preuve peut-être
qu'elle vote simplement plaidé le doute
raisonnable n'est pas forcé de témoigner
ce qu'on voit dans ce procès là c'est
souvent le traitement qui est fait aux
plaignantes en agression sexuelle c'est
toujours une étape difficile à passer
nous dans les cales axe on cherche à les
accompagner tout le long du processus
les encourager à porter plainte parce
qu'il s'agit quand même d'un crime mais
il ya peu de femmes qui portent plainte
vous n'êtes pas l'acteur principal
l'avenir on n'est pas l'acteur principal
merci beaucoup à vous de ce tirage